up until a little while ago he would
have never dreamed this could happen a
Syrian refugee invited to meet the
President of Germany at Bellevue Palace
monier al-sheikh is one of about 5,000
volunteers who will be honored at this
year's annual citizens celebration
German President URM gonk will pay
tribute to people who have shown a
particularly strong civic commitment to
Germany yada zubar design SML this is
super madam president it's the first
time I've been anywhere near the
president it's amazing that's Tolliver
nine I think it's great that a refugee
is allowed to be here at the palace not
common when he's not walking down red
carpets monier al-sheikh helps
immigrants in arnsberg a small german
town in north rhine-westphalia even
though he himself has only been in
germany for ten months a year ago he
came here to flee the war in Syria now
he's showing other refugees the ropes so
they can also do what it takes to become
integrated and that's exactly the kind
of engagement that the German president
wants to recognize he's a mansion to her
she's the outside movements of water
she'd be here albert is as different as
these people are and as varied as their
work is their attitude is the same they
want to be actively engaged in their own
lives and in society a man you probably
met me in a state they don't want to
just complain or walk away they want to
make an effort to help lon NZ and Seguin
owner al-sheikh is grateful that Germany
has taken in so many refugees that's
something he wishes he could tell the
president in person hello Connie shyam
brewing above the guru singh muffin
maybe I'll be able to greet him I'll say
thank you very much Germany for helping
refugees a year full of fleshly get here
and we the refugees promise that we will
work together with you Sophie so advise
the suzama saw Dwight moni el sheikh was
not able to deliver his message
personally but it was still a night to
remember